[Music]
okay serious question
when Doom was released back in 2016 how
many of you said man I really wish I
could play this while on the toilet
anyone anyone Hey no Jim I didn't ask
you put your hand down the real answer
is well probably not very many of you
yet here we are in 2018 with the power
to poo and pulverize demons all at the
same time and you know what I kind of
like it
with the switch having one year's worth
of experience under its belt I think
it's important that we should take a
look at one of the features that define
the switches dominance its Portability
now if you're just as excited as I am
about the switches anniversary check
back on GameSpot calm as we've got
plenty more videos looking at the
consoles incredible first year now we
all know portability isn't a foreign
idea to Nintendo they've perfected the
handheld system several times over with
their many iterations of the Game Boy
NDS but giving that trait to their
primary console the one that will house
the newest and best versions of Zelda
Mario and all their other franchises now
that's something new but they didn't get
here by sheer luck as we all know
Nintendo spent several years in which
another console with a portable screen
attached to the controller was their
main focus yes I'm talking about the Wii
U in retrospect the Wii U's short four
year lifespan almost felt like a testing
period with Nintendo gauging interest in
a portable console and refined the
technology to make it a reality
all while developing the many titles
that would eventually get a second
chance at life on the switch itself but
we know now that the switch is much more
than a slimmer Wii U it's become a
versatile piece of hardware that much
like a smartphone or tablet can feasibly
be taken anywhere we go and it's that
concept of portability alone that has
twisted our perception of how and why a
game is released on the switch no longer
do people groan at the idea of older
games being ported to the system we now
rejoice when they are I've already
mentioned the incredible bowel movement
inducing powers of doom but there's also
rocket League Bayonetta 1 & 2
Mario Kart 8 Super Meat Boy and
Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus just for
starters we've gotten to a point where
people are begging for games to be
released on the switch and for the first
time in a long while developers have a
good incentive to port their games to a
Nintendo console for example the indie
platformer Celeste was released on all
major platforms but the switch version
is currently outselling them all despite
having a smaller install base people are
seeing the switch as the best way to
play certain games and the portability
of the console is definitely a
contributing factor of course
portability might not apply to everyone
there are plenty of people who I'm sure
have no problem leaving their switch
nestled snugly in the dock with little
desire to take it anywhere and you know
what that's perfectly fine you can
choose to keep the console docked or
carry it around in your backpack because
that's the magic of the switch you
aren't constrained by any one form
factor you won't be handicapped if you
decide to take your switch on the go and
most importantly you can play it however
you want even if that means taking it to
the bathroom I hope you all enjoyed this
video I love my switch and I tend to
take it everywhere I go even if I don't
really use it it just kind of follows me
everywhere at this point but if you've
got any stories about you and your
switch or if you just want to scream
about how awesome it is feel free to put
it into the comments below we've been
doing videos this whole week celebrating
the switches first anniversary so make
sure you visit GameSpot comm to watch
all the other videos alright guys thanks
so much for watching and I'll see you
next time
[Music]